c'est bien ce que tu fais mais il ya des
moments où les gens décrochent c'est
tous les moments les gens et c'est bien
mais décroche là également on décroche
ce que tu sens - jenny 2001 vas-y
donatoni des sera jamais d'accord mais
tu as l'air tellement content en asie
donne l'atonie des mondes tessin quoi
quoi tu t'en fous sur la plage tu
démontes bien ténue barney gère rêve
quoi non t'es pas d'accord
ah non tu es vraiment chiante camp ouais
je suis chiante mais je t'en trouves
pourquoi tu veux pas démontrée parce que
je veux pas je te demande les voies
tessin venons justement personne les
voies mais ça sur la plage
c'est ce qui va t'arriver j'étends un
casting de potiche est la première bonne
que je trouve je la prends je te le dire
mais vas-y c'est dégueulasse mais vas-y
fais-le tant qu'actrice et mois
dégueulasses et la télé ok il serait
peut-être temps de commencer la
sélection des présents stellaire des
potiches dewi des potiches stellaire des
petits salaires chantal est ce qu'on
peut envoyer les petits stellaire s'il
te plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre votre nom maureen prénom maureen à
pardon c'est d'or votre âge n 2 ans
profession touristes appareil touristes
apparaît oui et voulait être petit chez
nous oui ça vous intéresse
oui pourquoi pas peut-être petitjean
d'autres endroits autant de potiche à la
télé est-ce que vous oui oui mais à la
télévision en direct devant les caméras
s'est dit pour lui qu'il caméra toutes
ces caméras là oui oui c'est d'accord
oui au désert salé d'accord thierry elle
est d'accord on va écouter mettez-vous à
côté du président lawrence est
présélectionné merci
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir votre prénom
je m'appelle géraldine oui votre nom
brisoult brézault vous êtes petit jeu
télé potiche
oui ça fait un petit moment que j'essaye
mais
peut-être que ce soir j'aurais
l'occasion j'espère cher public ferait
avec moi parce que sans vos modèles
beaux modèles de potiche sophie favier
annie pujol pour ce jour aviez c'est pas
évident parce que je crois que je vais
pas encore à la hauteur mais
qui sait peut-être qu'un jour avec la
silicone enfin vente ou même tenter
quelque chose vous admirez sophie et non
s'il aime beaucoup et agnès de canal à
6,6 aussi sont vos modèles de petits
champs quelque sorte
si vous malheur attendez je vous dire
tout de suite la fellation d'accord mais
pas la sodomie s'agit pas que ça pose un
petit problème quand même professeur
trop propret enfin si vous voulez on
bâche c'est pas moi non mais moi je suis
d'accord si c'est avec vous oui c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe aussi il
faut devant les caméras
a devant lui devant tout le monde bon
d'accord je veux bien
bon j'vais à bilzen
[Applaudissements]
jour plaide potiche henry elle entend
que vous l'êtes petit chez nous n'ont
pas très longtemps mais ce soir que ce
soir mais que c'est ça votre rêve de
petit c'est qu'ils ont tous dit son ouïe
bonne réponse répondu ardisson va bien
vous n'êtes pas présélectionné pourrait
passer par la petite yaris
c'est ça la télé des potiches depuis
depuis à peu près cinq ans sa fille oui
j'adore leurs deux petits ouais je me
suis blessé tout seul chez moi
abondamment arrosées quoi pourquoi votre
nom sylvie c'est donc votre prénom
syfia si oui même la sienne mais c'est
difficile vie je vis une vie ne marchait
pas très joli mon âge 25 ans son âge
celui ci lui aussi profession de s'y
glisser sur le petit mon petit je n'en
ai pas le moment c'est un petit jeu pour
le moment
ben j étais bon j'aime bien tout donner
comme ça on peut dans un endroit
je m'épanouis ouais mais est-ce que vous
c'est ça la question est-ce que je crois
est ce que je pense que vous ses défauts
ses dépenses adéquat mais là c'est
devant les caméras comme là bas s'est
dit qu'est ce que vous proposez projet
rien moi je vous demande s'ils vont si
je crois si je suis
les petits jeux c'est trop de tout ça
les petits cheveux ça reste en place
satan pour les arts aux beaux parents
sont au courant non notre vocation de
petits non non non c'est même très
strictes il ne faut pas trop les secrets
donc vous êtes prête à huy devant les
caméras devant les caméras sur le bureau
en direct sur nick vous êtes
présélectionnés site officiel du merci
[Applaudissements]
votre votre nom marina je suis je suis
la petite serre d'agnès boulard donc une
grande expérience des potiches puisque
je la vois travailler souvent à canal et
puis gelé un peu aidé dans ce métier au
début moi je suis prêt à tout aussi mais
si vous voulez comme une tâche
je m'appelle marina boulard marina bull
à la soeur d'années ce beau jardin
grande soeur votre âge 32 ans votre
profession je suis petit chopard si vous
voulez par alliance puisque agnès et
potiche et j'aurais bien aimé continuer
parce que dans la famille c'est une
tradition
oui je peux faire tout sur le bureau
j'aime bien comme adage j'aime bien
comme une batterie
bien relaie aussi au fait ça c'est
quelque chose qui me travaille fait rire
est marina je peux refaire le nez si
vous voulez si sévèrement
ouais c'est pas le nez le pire à ses
dessins sont un peuple a peut-être oui
est-ce que vous oui je aussi en direct
oui bon les caméras devant les caméras
bah vous êtes présélectionnés lors
marina merci beaucoup à vous
soir bonsoir votre prénom
koren notre nom merkel mcevoy redire
merkel mcevoy votre âge 21 ans
profession c'était deux heures que je
suis là et que j'attends pour ce casting
alors je crois c'est quoi votre
profession petit chercher un travail de
petites gelées pour le moins vous n'êtes
pas encore potiche je n'ai pas l'air
d'une potiche pour y être petit show
mais pour le moment votre profession
c'est quoi faty en attente
potiche en attendant l'a dit le
dupliquer un professeur existe
sélectionneur potiche en date un châle
conférences cafés avec doté absolument
est-ce que vous ne va pas dans la tête
toi pourquoi est-ce que je hais ce que
je crois c'est une cuisine et
ça va pas du tout vous ne savez pas dans
ne n'y a pas moyen de
non professeur est ce que vous pensez un
repêchage malgré tout avec dopé je pense
qu'on peut y mettre de paix propice au
score dans ce cas d'accord bon vous êtes
quand même présélectionnés donc bien m
bonjour brno cette année comment votre
âge 19 ans profession
je termine mon zappé de potiche c'est
moitié et j'espère que ça va bien se
passer
vous allez avoir le diplôme de potiche
bah j'espère enfin l'usap est pour
l'instant après je sais pas ce que j'ai
fait vous aimeriez de potiche hisse à la
télévision et je suis comme annie pujol
comme sophie favier comme indienne ians
c'est un peu votre rêve dans la vie bah
oui sur toi niasse est un modèle pour la
façon des deux présents tout ça c'est
vrai que là le petit chalet laurent
baffie c'est un modèle pour vous aussi
que potiche
- - apparemment - agnès est beaucoup
plus traditionnelle pour 1 voix que une
vraie potiche et nièces oui c'est un
modèle pour toutes les potiches est-ce
que vous tous les jours mais est-ce que
vous
en direct devant les caméras n'ont pas
bon vous êtes prête à devant les caméras
on l'applaudît elle est pré-sélectionnée
[Applaudissements]
grande qualifie de petit alors voilà une
autre potiche bonsoir alors vous l'êtes
petit chez nous donc votre nom votre
prénom
c'est rigolo oui votre âge et donc vous
voulez être potiche oui d'accord mais
est-ce que vous oui devant les caméras
vous n'avez pas un peu la grosse tête
un petit peu la grosse tête
est-ce que vos parents sont au courant
elle a de l'humour
l humour est sélectionné bien soin
[Applaudissements]
british
bonsoir mettre petit oui j'ai fait des
études mais je prends les cours du soir
pour être petit et ça vous fait pour que
la télévision j'imagine son planning sur
toi jane alias revient souvent
nico façon soudaine on nous a dit
pourquoi elle pourquoi pas peur il va
effectivement enfin tout cas je l'espère
votre nom emmanuel emmanuel commencer un
autre
pardon geindre votre votre âge jantes en
20 ans votre profession non je suis sans
profession pour l'instant je prends des
cours du soir pour être cotées mais
est-ce que vous oui ah ben oui vous êtes
oui mais là oui là d'accord d'accord
sans condamner j'ai un peu de mal à le
croire mais si on le désire a rapidement
peut-être est-ce que vos parents sont au
courant oui ma mère m'a poussé à niveau
6 ch
alors avec sa fille réussit louis pour
beaucoup de chocs l'affairé fait c'est
vous le dit thierry installez-vous
l'après du président lorrain qui ne m'en
demandez ça repart alors votre nom tu
m'appelles nathalie aguilar
ouais je suis une potiche à l'université
et je voudrais potiche à la télévision
pourquoi parce que
si c'est un état qui me conviendra
télévision des motifs vous admire et qui
comme potiche comme potiche
annie pujol annie pujol belles potées
agnès se fit favier par sophie favier
jeux wii pas tant que ça non pas tant
que ça est ce que vous êtes prête à oui
non si
ici ici ici même toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines devant les caméras
devant les caennais je suis si cette
volonté de réussir d'accord j'ai
d'accord je suis dacc de retard j'assume
[Applaudissements]
soir votre nom elena lna le prénom nom
oui c'est le prénom et le nom
pourquoi la bascule quand on va être
engagée faute de descendants son prénom
20 kg pour quoi pour qui je rends petit
pardon n'est pas une potiche
non non c'est quoi alors je ne veux pas
être potiche je ne sais pas où je suis
encore un peu jeune pour savoir ce que
je veux faire mon petit chemin qu'il
obtenait bonne chose oui pilote d'avion
le suggèrent les professeurs rené massat
ok d'accord
quel genre d'avion à l'égout et les
crozes avions ce qu'ils veulent dans le
ciel c'est possible évidemment c'est
plutôt par là je suis désolé les avions
c'est la place et les petits
votre nom martine marty gaz très jolie
votre présent mélissa mélissa martigues
al sadek el hadji 18 et vous voulez être
potiche
oui j'aimerais bien mais c'est
j'aimerais bien comme ça mais c'est une
vraie vocation
je suis pas sûr mais j'aimerais bien
savoir tustin oui sans regarder cette
étudiante en maîtrise hic
l'étudiante en maths physique j'aimerais
sincèrement houlette potiche qui
l'admirait vous comme potiche sur sophie
sophie hallette très grand mais si
sophie ah oui c'est sophie mais ses
soucis
oui je reconnais qu'il ya quelque chose
aussi flou bien elle siffle mes aïeux
nachtigal c'est le rossignol au malawi
oui c'est mon sac elle siffle comme cela
arrive mais vous savez que la télévision
on va pas expliquer on m'a juste donné
du champagne plein de chance j'avais
demandé qu'on leur explique un personne
vous a expliqué mettez-vous près du
président lorrain et pions j'avais un
avantage certain sur toutes les autres
et combien de 10% ses cachets s'est pas
caché caché
oui vous fait combien 95 bonnet b
effectivement j'ai déjà un gros gros
points pour envisager d'entrer à
l'agropole ça suffit pas non votre votre
prénom
safia votre nom s est ce votre
profession
comédienne vous êtes petit chat
télévision oui si c'est possible ça peut
l'être
nous cherchons une petit jeu pour cette
émission bon j'y suis ravi de la flandre
alors je me présente je vous savez que
oui j'ai appris ça oui mais s'il faut le
faire pourquoi pas les préservatifs mais
j'ai rien et moi j'apporte la saison non
je plaisante c'est vraiment dans cette
étude voilà j'ai pas dit non même si jc
série est incapable d'une telle pensée
ouais vraiment et je dis là apparemment
non je n'ai pas vos parents savent que
vous cherchez du travail comme potiche
oui ça les dérange pas mais ont vivement
encouragé
bah écoute et mettez-vous près du
président laura merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non hélène le moignic votre âge 25 ans
il ya longtemps que vous vous l'êtes pas
des chiens très longtemps très très très
longtemps je suis plombier depuis très
longtemps de mère en fille et je me suis
dit que potiche était quand même très
intéressant et l'appelant voyez vous
vous laissez tomber
ah oui pourquoi ça marche plus
vous savez que si vous êtes potiche
êtes prête à quoi elle dit
mais j'ai une préférence pour qui j'ai
une préférence pour moi je préfère la
sodomie à la fellation et surtout avec
un préservatif et j'ai un impératif que
ça se passe surtout toutes les semaines
toutes les spa oui devant l'éternel et
disent oui oui ah oui
ah oui j'vois pas de marrons je crois
qu'elle est pas mal parti
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous l'êtes petit chez nous vrai
prénom
géraldine géraldine comment maltazard
balthazar de décalage
vingt ans vingt ans vous faites quoi
dans la vie d'un potiche amateurs
potiche ou amateurs potiche amateurs
j'aimerais devenir protège confessions
vous faites ça vous potiche amateurs ben
pour l'instant je cherche je fais les
castings et là j'espère que ça va
marcher justement ça dépend de vous et
ce que vous je pense que vous savez que
je sais et vous seriez vous tuez le
mouiller mais devant les caméras de la
télévision a non pas bon non mais je
suis désolé vous n'êtes pas
présélectionné discussions chirac c'est
la télé c'est la dure loi de la
télévision marie rose
ça a l'air de vous rendre triste vous
appelez marie-rose notre nom de famille
cabanillas black potiche
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être potiche
devant moi cette décors et des émissions
de télévision comme annie pujol comme
sophie favier comme agnès à canal je
m'appelle air très tenté par safetic à
la télé non j'attends la télé qu'elle
qu'elle m'offre autre chose or justement
que de belles femmes vous allez en voir
des canons il y en a car et alain vit
pas mal non plus vous même
mais vu ce qui arrive
ouais wyeth petit sur arte ouais ouais
bah tu sais rareté c'est peut-être pour
potiche intelligente qu'un peu plus de
texte disant écoutez nous on va pas vous
garder mais on peut vous pistonné chez
arte pour être petit chéri gentil merci
on l'avenir l'encouragent et les
spectateurs un petit prénom je suis sûr
j'aime j'ai un grand monde un grand c
comme en famille d'origine rien contre
les aides sociales
j'espère bien n'est ce pas un professeur
si on a un petit quelque chose on le cas
j'en ai dit qu'on en parle et je pense
s'en remet à des alsaciens presse qui
est arrivé avec anne aymone dernièrement
donc vous avez la vocation d'être
potiche
j'espère bien j'ai pas fait d'études au
moins six chanteurs première dans la
salle les études c'est pas très
recommandé quand on m petits chats ont
poussé des études de droit
ouais ça demande beaucoup de personnes
alitées oui oui professeur je pense qu
elle oubliera vite son droit
oui
son bon droit l'esp est sélectionné
mettez-vous président lorrain qui la
fera un plaisir de vous accueillir un
petit cadeau cette location de petits
chats vous appris quand c'est inné chez
moi c'est chinelli potiche tu t'étais
déjà très potiche mais aujourd'hui vous
êtes grande petit oui 1 quel est votre
prénom
nadège annoncé jeudi nadège et votre nom
de famille 10/06 ayant demandé à petit
quelque chose mais nous le cas les
gagnants on avait dit on avait dit que
ce soir les irlandais on disait trop
rien non mais c'est pas grave on est pas
savez vous êtes au courant des
conditions de la vie de potiche
vous savez que la potiche une petit
cheptel n'importe quoi ça c'est bien
vous voyez je dois être prêtes à
n'importe quoi absolument surtout à
rester planté devant les caméras vous
savez sur très très longtemps fait chaud
vous savez qu'il faudra vous habiller
d'une façon un petit peu plus 1 est ce
qu'il ya eu un bon je crois beaucoup
d'énergie
[Applaudissements]
alalalala
bonjour très beaux yeux tu là mais il
faut toujours dire tu sais tu sais les
beaux yeux tu sais oui bah flore il va
carrément je m'appelle valérie et puis
voilà puis maintenant le nom de famille
c'est comment le nom de famille un prix
est inscrit sur la liste sur la fiche
que j'ai rempli tout à l'heure oui vais
pas le dire non mais c'est pas grave on
s'informe on va l'appeler ardisson bon
peu la plus récente
pourquoi où laura où laura c'est vrai où
l'orage si vous voulez je l'adopté
est ce que vous savez qu'à la télévision
on vous a expliqué absolument
vous savez que mais je sais que à la
télévision il faut être professionnel il
faut oser tout simplement oui je vais
davantage de choses je pense qu'il ya
une formation il faut rassembler tant la
pension le tard mais ça évolue au regard
théorie mais moi je ne soyez polis
savoir une personnalité nous en a pas
oui nous on n'apprend pas tellement sur
le tas en fin bouillon avec le temps on
apprend avec la table vous êtes
vous êtes d'accord donc pour eux mais
quand pourquoi pas pour celle télévision
jeux d'accord pour est hostile pour
potiche par postiches pas conformes
postiches c'est le journal de 20 heures
sur tf1
si ces antigènes potiche j'ai jamais
fait bouger vous n'avez jamais fait
absolument voulu essayer oui d'entente
et quand ces nouveaux faux tampon c'est
bien vous a l'air de vous à l'air d'en
vouloir
oui j'en veux mais on n'a pas toujours
ce qu'on veut
oui donc on essaie bon mais mettez vous
pourrez du président lorrain qui va se
passer
[Applaudissements]
très intelligent très bon soir
votre prénom simone notre nom de famille
seaman saviez en fait mon père a eu une
aventure avec une dame qui est la maman
de qui vous savez que je fais qui
travaille aussi pour une émission télé
vision que je peux pas nommer mais guy
et moi de ma pelle simone pour une dame
aussi avec une aventure mais je voulais
que potiche des travaillent et défilent
et même cour que sophie et de données
que j'étais beaucoup plus doux et
qu'elle met les bons mois mais l'étude
m'ont pris beaucoup de temps pour
étudier les dom
et puis la bombe est un peu de temps
j'aimerais bien fabien télévision mais
tout à fait c'est tout à fait possible
c'est tout à fait pensable est ce que
vous savez que la télévision est ce que
vous êtes prête
oui mais mes parents font pas tellement
courant que j'ai pas parlé de coucher
moi c'est vous qui parlez trop chez
l'abonné mmm a habitués à faire
bah oui oui oui ça peut aider remarqué
mais c'est pas toi moi ça que je pensais
mais bon c'est pas tout oui oui peut
faire petit jeu peuvent atteindre le
studio oui c'est d'ailleurs ma vie
est-ce que vos parents sont au courant m
et par un fonds mort dans un accident de
voiture
donc tu vois ça vous fait rire non mais
c'est pas ça tu peu désolant de lire des
choses comme ça professeur ah oui encore
dans un accident de train vous pouvez
rire franchement soixante sont vite quoi
donc oui oui c'est déjà bon et vous êtes
présélectionnés si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir votre prénom
ouais ouais nom de famille ouais ouais
ouais vous voulez être petit jeu donc
oui oui c'est vrai devait déjà l'air
très très petit cv et vos parents sont
de ses parents sont d'accord professeur
est ce que ce n'est pas la soeur d'une
personne que nous avons eu tout à
l'heure elle lui ressemble beaucoup
elle lui ressemble beaucoup je pense
qu'on peut là je pense un je pense qu'on
peut la pré sélectionnés demandé au
président laurent de l'accueillir
président lorrain il est très très bien
un peu terre à terre mais ça très bien
[Applaudissements]
stéphanie votre nom de famille lalo
votre profession je n'ose pas le dire
parce que je voudrais potiche mais un
bon show maquilleuse et alors qui dit un
petit peu cruche et viendrait prendre
acte
[Applaudissements]
je suis tu te couches
soit votre prénom la petite colère j'ai
alors connaître comment dimanche au oui
votre âge doit-on - professeurs n'ont
pas pipé nerveux cela c'est ça oui c'est
vrai c'est peut-être le mouvement le
plus important de votre vie
ouais je sais pas trop mais vous n'êtes
pas tish au nom de tous les trucs je
suis déçu je suis désolé quand elle
entend envoyer le casting de fétiches
j'avais un petit prénom c'est ma peine
ni ni ni ni vote nom de famille mouscou
roger je sais que très connu dans les
spectacles mais je peux pas dire son nom
aujourd'hui je viens de graisse comme
elle aimait par une très grosse
désillusion lesquels donc j'ai décidé de
relever le numéro le niveau de la
famille oui c'est pour ça que faire un
petit chien ou potiche dans une émission
mais qu'on voudrait bien vous savez que
si je dois je faire
corti le score
[Applaudissements]
as tu t'es fait piéger bêtement troph en
patron à jeter piéger bêtement ces
transferts patron philippe ventes
avaient jusqu'au bout mais oui je t'ai
pas reconnu mes amours je me suis douté
j'ai je sais pas pourquoi c'est la
bouche me wehr j'ai dit corti le score
j'ai dit là il va se découvrir et utd
courageux peut pas quand j'entends ça me
fait mal au coeur
le score a été obligé de le dire de
rollin à la palme et rosazia oui je t'ai
dit qu avait rien pour toi dans cette
émission même pas postiches postiches
6,6 postiches et on peut s'arranger en
tout cas pas faire ça à moi aussi ça m'a
fait plaisir de te revoir philippe
gardent
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je suis un petit peu ému
c'est trop bête cette histoire de cortix
pompiers de monthey trois morts à droite
et m'asseoir devant sur la chaise devant
thierry jusque là ça va donc compter
jusqu'à trois oui c'est déjà pas mal
c'est même pour une potiche n'est même
pas utile je dirais m'enfin bon temps
ouais compté jusqu'à dot a beau y mettre
à l'aise mais c'est même souhaité et
[Applaudissements]
guitare l'état oui votre nom et tarita
car votre âge 32
ouais quoi benoît s'est pas limitée
non non non pas des potiches même plus
âgés atteints gestion non non vous avez
la vocation à vouvry ça vous a
complètement vraiment way sur wii je me
savais que quoi bon
vous savez que non mais quoi
je sais pas moi non dites moi
vous êtes prête un gpu on m'avait dit de
répondre plus j'ai complètement ville
septet wiki forêt pour vraiment oui oui
oui vous êtes prête à complètement oui
oui raconté n'a pas de mémoire ça me
semble une très bonne petite allée chez
lanvin
mettez le tout de suite là bas vous êtes
prévenus
[Applaudissements]
peut-être avez-vous négliger les
problèmes de cadrage que pourra poser
notre ami non non non non non
sélectionné je suis désolé pour
l'avionneur
notre ami est sélectionné d'office d'un
fils de ma cousine a pas d'accord en
tout cas bonsoir votre prénom
jennifer votre nom de famille
jennifer tout court vous avez quel âge
30 ans voulaient est petit il rêve de
votre vie vous savez que courant
d'accord pour tout sinon vous seriez pas
là ce que vous êtes prête à tout c'est
ici nous avions une potiche qui
s'appelait sandrine s'est pas très bien
passé avec nous je vous en prie ne s'est
pas très bien passé avec nous parce que
sandrine a refusé de montrer ses seins
est ce que vous seriez prête à montrer
les vôtres montrer les je vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
professionnel
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il ya un professeur mais
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un problème avec un
top top faute mais c'est le problème
quand on est avec cendrillon
déontologique contre le service public
je regarde le barème une paire de seins
nus ça va vous coûter 13 secondes à man
ray secondes de barredo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chemin de sa noble errance le grand
canal à l'endroit précis où il est le
plus étroit se laisse enjambé par le
rialto cette arche de marbre qui d'un
seul jet aggrave solidement les deux
partis flottantes voilà que ça vous sert
de leçon
voici les résultats de notre grand
casting de petits chemins à menzel
messieurs je vous demande d'applaudir
celles qui ont su séduire la france les
yeux dans les yeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qu'il était impossible de départager
stéphanie emmanuel et valérie nous avons
décidé en total accord avec sophie
favier agnès boulard laurange de sacrée
soirée et annie pujol de les engager
toutes les trois pour faire trois fois
plus d'audience
hardy matt a désormais trois fois plus
de petits ça changeait quoi dans ta vie
de passer à la télé tous les samedis
soirs et bien déjà ça m'apporte une
occupation en plus et je suis mieux d'un
pauvre way sexuellement ça changeait
quelque chose ou non tout ce qu'il faut
par ailleurs c'est à dire eh bien ça va
ça vient quand gilles et m papillon et
un peu plus son jules il ya disons que
il réfléchit davantage aux actes qui tu
fais ah bon c'est à dire il est
préoccupé par ce que je fais donc il se
méfie davantage de ski 10 puis fait plus
attention à son attitude il t'aime plus
j'espère j'espère qu'ils m'aiment plus
alors un manuel ça changeait quoi dans
ta vie tu passais tous les samedis soirs
à télévision va 1 contrairement à
valérie le seul menu célibataire donc à
branges et oui mais vous voyez quitter
parce qu'il était jaloux n'en finit pas
de quoi bassi m'a dit c'est lui vous
tirez indices ont donc gérable et
thierry éventuelle avancée fini c'est
fini on sexuellement ça va beaucoup plus
mal maintenant comment fini pour toi là
oui toi tu vas trouver un autre jules je
sais pas trop de soucis un ça va
non merci et toi lance tiffany ça
changeait quoi de passer la télévision
tous les samedis soirs ça a changé tant
de choses par exemple
à taper dans la rue
vraiment ces familles qui métisse est ce
que tu vis ton métissage comme une forme
d'exclusion
c'est dur
y'en a beaucoup souffert lorsque tu
étais enfant
oui c'est quand on est petit c'est
vraiment dur à supporter
là bas c'est pas c'est pas chez toi ici
on rejette
finalement c'est quoi ton au lieu de vie
je sais pas j'arrive pas à me retrouver
je me sens pas chez moi nulle pa
est ce que est ce que le regard des gens
de 2 pèse 6
c'est la solitude toujours soit pas
facile
est ce que c'est cette différence a
empêché trouver un emploi je crois
je crois ce que je cherche depuis
longtemps j'étais problème
est ce que tu crois que cette double
origine ta interdit vraie histoire
d'amour
oui
merci de ta sincérité c'était vraiment
bien merci je vous ai donné un bon coup
de main pour l'audience c'est sympa
ainsi stéphanie hockey thierry accord on
ne bouge pas c'est bien qu'on fasse une
petite larme sur ces familles d'accord
d'accord chanter à des problèmes
d'accord on va te mettre une petite
larme c'est pour des des plans de coupe
tu sais
ouais bien larmes bien un parfait la
larme
c'est déchirant fait ouais tu veux pas
ressasser la dernière question avec la
larme chantal non thierry c'est très
bien comme ça vend d'accord la raie bien
base il ajouté l'air vraiment voilà mais
c'est bien là
ouais c'est bien tout voilà
ok tu là merci on applaudit et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux